[Musique]
oui alors c'est une information qui
concerne donc effectivement les
supermarchés surtout les consommateurs
car vous savez que nous sommes nous
étions en période de blocage de fa pas
blocage des prix de trêve des treilles
prix vous restiez de mesurer le taux de
l'inflation et donc c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour les consommateurs
apparemment puisque le monsieur georges
qui est président de l'union des
supermarchés vient d'annoncer un nouveau
blocage de ces prix je suis allée
l'interviewer mais vous allez voir que
c'est peut-être un petit peu décevant en
tous les cas nous écoutons ces
explications
et lyon monsieur georges parce qu'il
fallait appuyer sur une [ __ ] pour
faire démarrer le sujet quelques
secondes avant et j'avais oublié alors
donc ça va arriver d'ici conscient de la
politique menée par monsieur le ministre
de l'économie et en tant que partenaires
sociaux nous nous devons d'être
solidaire et pour cela nous allons mener
une deuxième campagne de trêve des prix
une campagne qui commencera le lundi 5
avril et cela jusqu'au 5 juillet et
avant nous sommes obligés de refaire
certains réajustements qu'est ce que
vous entendez par réajustement et bien
nous devons réinventer nos stocks et des
rajustements doivent être faits vu
l'augmentation du coût de la vie et pour
ceux là ne sont amenés à augmenter
certains prix tels le café le chocolat
certains produits laitiers les alcools
notamment si je comprends bien avant de
bloquer les prix vous aller les
augmenter
oui une augmentation
c'est la vie ça augmente ça baisse ça
augmente c'est ça c'est quand même pas
très normal oui
pas norman il faut faire un effort mais
alors là j'ai contentent plus d'une
personne sur six est un blocage d'une
augmentation c'est un blocage des prix
mais c'est toujours au consommateur
qu'on demande de faire des efforts pour
augmenter de 85 points ou 2 ans le lait
de 72% le café 2 97% les alcools de 150%
alors on nous dit qu'on bloque les prix
mais voyez la politique souvent
pratiquée par un supermarché je crois
que c'est quand même assez gérable que
vous avez eu raison de mettre l'accent
sur cette anomalie c'est une véritable
anomalie
enfin la dernière mesure qui je pense
sera blanc semble des français laissant
sera gratuite je dis bien gratuite les
vendredis de 14 à 16 heures et les
lundis de 10 à 11 heures nous voulons
aider l'industrie automobile qui connaît
actuellement une période très difficile
et par la même occasion favoriser
l'étalement des départs et des rentrées
pour les week-ends messieurs que pensez
vous de la décision de monsieur otto de
offrir l'essence gratuite le vendredi de
14 heures à 16 heures
attendez je reprends ma respiration
quand j'ai une très bonne décision y a
bien fait il ya bien fait puisque tous
les vendredis c'est aussi parce j'ai
demandé si fabien tout à fait d'accord
ils seront enfin tous les vendredis
entre 14 et 16 c'est fait c'est fait à
partir de la semaine prochaine c'est
mieux en mieux elle a tous pensé vous
avez parfois davantage en un week end et
non pas ce que je fais deux mille
kilomètres par semaine pour mon travail
alors le dimanche
roule le moins possible le week-end les
astres et quand votre essence de
vendredi bassil et que sont pas trop
longue je suis très content en peluche
militaire oui mais alors est ce que vous
saviez que c'était gratuit absolument
pas au quel effet ça vous fait
surprenant surtout en ce moment sa
superbe par contre est une bonne
nouvelle c'est facile ça pour une vrai
ce serait très bien
non vraiment vraiment j propre or
qu'est-ce que vous allez pas très bien
vrai ça bien oui évidemment mais ça
m'étonnerait pas une plaisanterie ce qui
me présenterai
nouvelles dispositions pré électorale
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est démagogique ce pareil
tu as fait quelques arpents
[Musique]
ces petites automobiles feront bientôt
partie du paysage quotidien des
bisontins facilement maniable et ouverte
à tous même aux personnes sans permis
ses voitures sillonneront bientôt les
rues de besançon pour l'instant
seulement trois de ces engins sont
disponibles les une dizaine d'autres
devraient être mis en circulation dans
les semaines à venir pour les utiliser
c'est très simple il suffit d'introduire
dans une fente une carte bleue qui
développe le système de sécurité les
clés elles sont en permanence sur le
contact à partir de ce moment là vous
pouvez conduire cette auto pendant 5 km
maximum ce qui vous coûtera seulement 20
francs prélevés sur votre compte
l'inventeur de ce système pense ainsi
résoudre les problèmes de circulation à
besançon et bien besançon ayant des
problèmes énormes de circulation la
ville est en très étroite
j'ai tout simplement penser aux petites
voitures sans permis qui elles ne
tiennent pas de place se gardent un peu
dans tous les sens et passe également
dans l'axé rouge
qui nous permet d'accéder partout vous
n'avez pas peur que les gens
s'approprient vos voitures non je ne
pense pas les bisontins pour
suffisamment honnête
compétent pour ne pas s'approprier ces
légumes
mais la paternité de ce projet revient
en fait à boris vian qui dans les années
50 avait imaginé ce système il était
même allé plus loin en proposant de
supprimer les voitures particulières un
public auto service on espère que les
bisontins respecteront ces voitures qui
finalement appartiennent à tout le monde
aujourd'hui c'était le premier jour
d'essais et nous avons déjà rencontré
des usagers est satisfait
normal c'est pas mal c'est amusant le
seul ce problème pour la dea
les jambes
le dégradent pas trop on va faire une
certaine concurrence à la ctb je pense
avec ça
aussi bien
en temps monsieur comment vous trouvez
ce nouveau système de voitures public
c'est bien pratique c'est très pratique
c'est mieux que le bus en fin de compte
parce qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas serré
comme mais comme des sardines j'aime
bien c'est bien enfin il ya la carte
bleue ça défavorise ceux qui n'ont pas
de carte bleue
un des problèmes les plus préoccupants à
paris celui de la circulation pour
circuler il faut effectivement pour voir
rouler il faut aussi pouvoir s'arrêter
il faut pouvoir avoir des parkings les
pouvoirs de paris le préfet de paris le
préfet de police ont déjà mis au point
un certaine mesure des parkings des
souterrains ils ont élargi des voies
rétrécies les trottoirs mais d'ores et
déjà les pouvoirs publics sont en train
de préparer de nouvelles mesures pour
connaître ces mesures nous avons mené
une enquête voulez-vous la suivre
pour faciliter la circulation dans le
centre de paris en particulier dans les
quartiers d'affaires les pouvoirs
publics étudient actuellement la
possibilité d'interdire totalement la
circulation des automobiles en
recommandant pour l'automobiliste
l'utilisation des bicyclettes mais que
pensent les parisiens de ce projet j'ai
entendu parler de ce projet oui oui
personnellement j'ai fait du vélo dans
mon plus jeune âge et à la cvb donc dans
ces conditions je pense que on peut
quand même appuyer sur les pédales
malheureusement c'est on est arrivé à un
siècle les gens n'aiment pas faire un
effort on a personnellement moi je
préfère la voiture que la bicyclette
parce que la bicyclette faut pédaler
vous avez déjà fait la bicyclette au wi
fi genre fait avec mais il n'y avait pas
tant de voitures vous êtes contre ce
projet absolument c'est un retour pour
moi de 50 ans en arrière comprenez la
bicyclette c'est fini c'est fini et là
où je suis et crise ou non non vous est
favorable à ce projet ah oui moi je suis
tout à fait pour je suis tout à fait
pour c'est un instrument très très
pratique je pense que pour une femme
c'est idéal pour aller chez son coiffeur
pour les uns ce petit cours pouvaient
absolument plus circuler place vendôme
pouvait plus stationner avec une
bicyclette très très facile
monsieur si vous êtes au courant d'un
projet qui consiste à réserver certains
quartiers à usage des cyclistes oui j'ai
entendu parler de ce projet d'ailleurs
j'ai déjà commencé à celle bicyclette dp
je m'exerce ont tous les matins et le
soir entre rentrer chez moi du gunner
chemin et y est sédentaire je travaille
dans un bureau donc ça me permet de
prendre de l'exercice merci je voulais
santé au travail merci
ah non je suis très surpris et que
pensez vous de ce projet
part je n'en pense rien c'est mais pour
l'instant je trouve que c'est assez
marrant parce que vous rendez compte
remplacer les voitures par les
bicyclettes en plus de ça les mini jupes
très intéressant pour nous alors si on
vous demande justement d utiliser
prochainement la bicyclette qu'est ce
que vous ferez que je le ferai
face à gré mais quand vous portez je
vois eu dix jours puisque sera pas
gênant pour vous non parce que c'est une
jupe culotte
j'ajouterai une bicyclette
ben mon choix que ce soit excellent
parce que nous allons voir 3 millions
véhicules dans peu d'années évidemment
ça résoudrait les problèmes de
circulation ne sera pas mal vous savez
pour nous ça nous arrangerait bien sa
revanche que tout le monde se croit sa
déco je suis un peu la circulation vous
permettra de circuler pour vous parler
d'accord ça pour ça oui
pierrot beau je crois que vous avez été
séduit par ce projet a finalement à tout
à fait séduit et voyez vous pouvez le
constater je me suis mis je suis ce
projet parce que c'est une chose très
importante et il faudrait que tous les
camarades de l'actualité télévisée fasse
la même chose les rues de paris serait
ainsi dégarni on roulerait beaucoup plus
vite et pour le sport quels progrès et
bien l'appel de pierre roubaud a déjà
été entendu et dès cet après midi une
équipe de l'actualité télévisée
partaient un reportage à bicyclette
à l'évaluer
pas tous encore possible parce que nous
ne sommes pas arrivés en europe où des
analyses mais on peut déjà dire que
toulouse repose sur eux un véritable lac
de petro absolument ahurissant sans
lloris en forme il a d'autant plus que
c'est en plein centre de la ville c'est
merveilleux mais est ce que on ne
l'avait pas penser jusqu'à présent on
n'avait rien découvert moi j'ai été
contacté il ya environ 18 mois pour la
recherche doivent être indiquées des
suintements dit par ici pétrolifères et
j'ai été chargé de thé un certain fouara
oui je viens
mais bon là
voilà pourtant monsieur l'ag universel
vous plaît vous avez atteint quelle
profondeur en fait seul chez mario loyer
en ce moment si nous faisons un forage
l'à-peu-près à 15 cents mètres ce que
tout à fait normal mais nous et à y
mettre trouver des nappes à 25 mètres
afin de sa dette oui oui et il est la
nature du sous-sol enfin autour de ce
soit un petit peu des terrains d'hiver
n'est ce pas tout à fait normal en
général on trouve les nappes de pétrole
sur du jurassique supérieur et de
l'émigré tout à fait normal et tenez en
ce moment si le fera ce que nous voulons
faire là on vient de tomber sur un album
chez quelqu'un après avoir traversé les
océans inférieur marc de
tandt et moi c'est pour et de pétrole
et quelle est la qualité de ce pétrole
or extraordinaire oui c'est à dire et à
dire vrai que habituellement
danger dans une production de pétrole
normal vous avez des quantités d'essence
à la sortie qui sont de l'ordre de 10 2%
le environ 37 30 % de bitume 30% de
gazole 30 % de produits divers et bien
ici la situation est absolument avait un
grand père s'est renversé comment ça se
présente sans se présente que en essence
pure ce pétrole à une teneur d'environ
77 à 80 % selon les dires d'un ami à
gruissan et l'exploitation se présente
comment l'exploitation alors là il
s'agit d'un autre problème qui
évidemment des patrons de moncade mais
il est hors de doute qu'il va falloir
d'ici peu absolument rasé faire sortir
tout ce qui se trouve entre la place du
capitole et la baronne
inconvénient c'est que ces nageurs comme
inconvénient au nom non plutôt avantage
avantage pascal riou c'est tellement
riche que comme chacun maintenant à son
plus d'eau douce la maison de campagne
et bien un dc10 12 en étant pessimiste
chacun chaque toulousain aura sans fil
pétrole personnel et qu'elle pétrole
réellement ses qualités
[Musique]
super oui mais combien de garantie
je comprends rien du tout
il sera désormais possible de respirer
l'air vivifiant des hautes vosges sans
quitter la chambre ces boîtes d'air pur
comprimés sont prêtes à être lancées sur
le marché à un prix modique elles seront
mis en vente dans les pharmacies et dans
les rayons spécialisés des grands
magasins les personnes atteintes
d'asthme pourront se faire rembourser
par la sécurité sociale c'est un
industriel vosgien qui a eu l'idée de ce
commerce encore inédit en france
constatant que nombreux étaient les
parisiens et même les lorrains qui
délaissait leur seul embrumé pour venir
respirer l'air des montagnes il a décidé
de livrer l'air pur à domicile
[Musique]
pour ce faire il a mis en place une
installation très compliqué l'air pur
encore vif et turbulent est à s'agit
cependant d'une tuyauterie longue de 10
km il est maintenu à une température
constante de + 2 degrés par un système
de régulation manuel un spécialiste
vérifie sa pureté deux fois par jour ils
remplacent les filtres chargé de retenir
les microbes
c'est alors seulement qu'intervient la
mise en boîte une boîte d'air de saint
litres peut durer un mois à raison de
deux inhalation par jour pour se
comprennent la précaution de la
conserver au réfrigérateur
[Musique]
cette commercialisation d'un de nos
biens les plus naturels l'air à quelque
chose d'inquiétant elle a aussi une
conséquence sociale ne va-t-on pas voir
disparaître l'un des petits métiers si
sympathique de nos campagnes le brasseur
d'air
[Musique]
le brasseur d'air artisanale a pourtant
beaucoup de mérite il faut du nez et une
solide résistance à l'euphorie car comme
chacun sait est l'air pur et grisant
[Musique]
les médecines naturelles à présent elle
rencontre un essor considérable
actuellement et ils peuvent surprendre
l'ouvragé du docteur mûri qui vient de
paraître met en relief l'influencé
positive de la bière sur la santé de
l'individu d'autre part un médecin de
haute-saône vient de découvrir des
vertus thérapeutiques à un autre produit
naturel la cancoillotte elle peut en
effet combattre efficacement les
rhumatismes c'est ici près de chambly
qui habite le docteur gros une
rhumatologue qui a choisi de vivre et de
travailler loin des villes après
plusieurs années de recherche à besançon
elle a décidé de s'isoler pour trouver
d'autres méthodes thérapeutiques
marginalisé par ses confrères le docteur
gros est en train de prendre une belle
revanche avec une invention
révolutionnaire
l'utilisation de la cancoillotte comme
moyen de guérison ces patients souffrent
d'un cas très très intéressant de
fiction douloureux ses articulations
nous allons donc lui appliquer cette
méthode révolutionnaire de coke wiotte
chaude préalablement max malaxer sur les
points très très sensible qui se situe à
peu près la hauteur des épaules
pour l'instant cette méthode originale a
permis d'obtenir des résultats tout à
fait spectaculaire avec un taux de
guérison totale de plus de 90%
bref un miracle on doit en plus à la con
coyolles le fromage symbole de la région
de quoi réjouir tous les francs comtois
mais au fait quel type de cancoillotte
faut-il utiliser celle au vin blanc ou
sel au beurre coûté la meilleure qu'au
royaume évidemment la confiance qu'on
fabrique soi même c'est à dire
avec bien sûr raconte petite pointe
d'ail et un petit peu de poivre pour
relier
les représentants des écrivains paysans
très attachés à leur terroir ou
considéré comme le rhumatologue paysanne
tout à fait je suis très attaché à
m'interroge sur moi-même franc comtoise
de souche et je revendique tout à fait
le titre de rhumatologues paysage le
docteur d'euros est actuellement en
contact avec des rhumatologues
américains et japonais se serait dommage
pour notre pays qu une fois de plus une
de nos inventions obtient la
consécration l'étranger avant même
d'être reconnu en france
[Musique]